Picture this.
It's a warm summer night in San
Francisco.
We are at the new PlanetScale office
downtown, right off Market Street.
Sam Lambert, the CEO, is there. He's in
a great mood. New office, room full of
cool people, he has a drink in hand, you
get the idea. I'm talking to Sam about
how PlanetScale gets customers.
And Sam says something I wasn't
expecting.
He says,
"I just love Twitter. You would be
shocked if I told you how many customers
we get from my own account.
I work with about 50 startups every
year, and I know just how much founders
hate this part of the job. So, I asked,
"Don't you ever get tired of it? You
can't delegate it, you know." It has to
be you.
Sam smiles and says, "I would never give
it up. It's my literal favorite thing to
do." That conversation has been rattling
in my head for days. I think Sam just
mentioned the most underrated
competitive advantage in startups in
2026. It's not your model,
it's not your team,
it's not your funding,
it's you.
Quick context on why I'm telling you
this.
I'm Victoria Melnikova, and I run new
business at Evil Martians.
We're a consultancy for developer tools.
We have a blog that has half a million
technical readers every year, and I run
a podcast about the business of
developer tools called Dev Propulsion
Labs.
My job is to figure out the business of
developer tools.
Building software has never been easier,
which means that the bottleneck has
moved. Now, the bottleneck is the
distribution.
And today, I want to talk to you about
what works as go-to-market for developer
tools in 2026.
I say that go to market is you. Well,
your personal brand. And I actually have
evidence to back that up. At Evil
Martians, we developed product market
fit compass. It's this framework that
tells us exactly what needs to be done
for a devtool company to achieve product
market fit.
It's a mathematical formula. We analyzed
37 successful devtools and derived a
graph. Basically, it consists of
two axes, product signal and revenue. If
product signal is stronger than revenue,
we need to work on distribution. If
revenue is stronger than the signal, we
need to work on the product. If signal
and revenue are the same, we just go
forward full speed.
We work with early stage developer tools
startups, and nine out of 10 times,
product signal is actually stronger than
revenue.
Why, you ask me? Well, technical
founders really hate marketing.
So, distribution is something that we
need to fix. And the truth is, in 2026,
distribution is really, really hard.
AI made our inboxes and feeds
unpairable. There is so much annoying
outreach and generated slop that it's
really hard to tell the real deal.
And it's really hard to cut through the
noise. So, what I invite you to do is I
want you to revisit some of the
conversations I had with successful
devtool founders here in NASSCOM and
learn from them. And we'll begin with
just basic go to market hygiene.
Uh
I will walk you through five simple six
simple steps
uh that will create foundation for our
go to market motion.
First, we need to crystallize our value
proposition. We really need to
understand the
the painful problem that we're solving,
and we need to validate that value with
paying customers. It's very important
that those customers are willing to pay.
Then we need to understand where in the
life of a developer we live. So, we need
to understand the shelf space.
Once we understand that shelf space, we
understand what channels to use to
distribute our product, and we can
become the authority on the problem.
Then we need to get a good sense of the
ecosystem. We need to friend our friends
and cross-pollinate. And we need to know
our foes, so we can distinguish
ourselves from them.
Finally, this is something that
technical founders really hate to do,
but this is really something super
important. We need to distribute early,
sometimes even before the product is
ready.
The first big lesson that we can take
away from SF-based devtool founders is
come to San Francisco.
>> [gasps]
>> San Francisco is great because here you
can meet your clients and friends in
person.
And there is this whole notion that if
after YC you stay in SF, you fundraise
twice as much, twice as fast. This
applies to fundraising, of course. All
the VCs are here, so if you're in the
fundraising game, you have to be here as
well.
>> Uh I try and talk to folks that are
newer in the industry or they're
building things and try and chat with
them, and and this is a place to make
that really easy. So, I think SF is
going to stay strong for that.
It's very hard to unseat those.
>> And David Cramer, founder of Sentry, put
it even more bluntly.
>> I think there's like a network thing. If
you can get to SF, despite what people
would like to tell you, SF is unfair.
Just do it. Who cares? Who cares about
what the internet memes say? Like SF is
like it's like a network game, right?
Like especially if you want to like do
the founding thing or or the venture
thing, like it is so unfair if you have
access to SF.
>> Once you're in SF, you have to get loud.
You have to advertise.
SF is big on the banners. You can see
them on the Muni buses. You can see them
on buildings. There are banners on the
highways.
Banners in SF do two things. It's
signaling. You are sending a strong
message to the world that you exist.
Potentially, you even invented a new
category, and you want to be loud about
that. Um and of course, you want to earn
mind share. What this means is that they
memorize you on a subconscious level.
>> And also, it helped
establish
Type Sense as a
brand that, you know, because we're not
a BC back company,
we don't have funding milestones to
share to say
to say, "Okay, hey, we're we're on a
good trajectory." So, we needed to find
a proxy for that, and
billboards are expensive.
So, we realized, "Okay, this is this
could be one way
as an our own credibility mechanism to
say that, 'Hey, we're not And and it And
that's the feedback we also got now that
the billboards have been, you know,
around for a couple of months, and
that's the feedback we've been, you
know, getting is that, 'Oh, I didn't
realize you were this big that you could
do, you know, hundreds of billboards
in SF.' So,
>> Once you're in SF, of course, you have
to do events. And there are different
ways to do this, and probably this is
like a huge separate topic, but
basically, you can organize events, you
can come to events. When it comes to
organizing events, you can do small
events, and you can choose whatever
format you want. You can play paddle,
poker,
uh do breakfast, do dinners, do lunches,
do boba time.
Uh you can do technical meetups. You can
do launch parties. You can do user
conferences. There is really really like
a lot to
a lot to tackle there. And now it's
becoming more common for earlier stage
startups to host their own user
conferences.
Uh you can learn from the industry's
best. Like folks like Superbase are
doing their Superbase Select second year
in a row.
>> I think everyone
eventually aspires to have their own
user conference. And for us
we have discussed it for many years and
we kind of internally have a no
conference policy. Like as in we don't
attend many conferences. We just put our
heads down and do work.
And then this year, for whatever reason,
it wasn't me who chose it.
The momentum built and
someone decided that now was the year.
And I guess there was enough consensus
built that we should do this.
>> And do crazy things. Fly a banner over a
sub. Do a crazy marketing campaign. Open
a cafe. Um brand your coffee. Name an
ice cream.
I love a sub because founders here are
just doing crazy things and they work.
And I think that whenever you have fun
with your marketing, it really really
comes through and shows. This one is
special because
failing actually attracts people to your
brand.
Um everyone wants to be perfect, but
perfect is boring and people just love a
good fail story, especially if there is
like an elegant recovery from it.
I invite you to think about your
failures
as opportunities.
>> starting from scratch, you know, because
you walked away from
ARR of what? 3
>> We had 300,000, yeah.
>> That's a solid ARR, you know.
>> Especially pre-AI, not terrible, yeah.
>> Yeah, it sounds great. You walked away
from that. You started from scratch. Now
looking back at it, are you happy about
that move?
>> Absolutely. Should have done it sooner.
Yeah, it's always like, you should have
done that sooner.
>> I mean, sooner would be too early.
>> I guess, maybe. Maybe 2 months before
would have been better.
>> Finally,
um I want to invite you to be
unapologetically you.
Uh
everyone has unique quirks, and
if you think about it, your unique
quirks can become your genius zone.
Something that comes naturally to you,
something that you're really passionate
about. This could really become a pillar
for your personal brand.
Uh the good news is the pendulum is kind
of running back to the artisanal. People
love craft, people love beautiful
designs, people love beautiful text. It
really resonates with the audience. So,
despite all the AI automation that's
available to us, I think people still
prefer a beautiful crafted experiences.
So,
for us technical folks, that's that's a
good chance to execute. And the way I
see AI is it cannot really replace you,
but it can amplify your signal, right?
So, whatever you bring forward, AI can
amplify, whether that's text, videos,
whatever it is.
I suggest you think about
your own personal traits and ways in
which AI can amplify that on your
personal level and on a brand level, on
a team brand level.
People want to buy personally from you.
Founder-led sales is one of the main
motions, especially for early-stage
startups, for a reason.
That's how trust is built. People want
to see a real human behind the product.
Here's what Zen Rocha says about that.
>> I feel like I I try not to overthink my
personal brand as much, or like have
like, "Oh, here's my food strategy, you
know? I just try to be myself because
that's how I feel like people are are
drawn to folks that are they try not to
impersonate or or or be someone else.
So, I just try to be as organic as
possible.
>> Your personal brand is the moat.
Founders that learn to leverage their
personal brand will stand out. In 2026,
in 2030,
as AI gets better, we'll only have an
ability to amplify that even more, but
it's going to be very hard for AI to
replace our unique brands.
I would like to invite you to think
about you. What are some quirks and
genius zones that you have?
What are some things that come naturally
and organically to you? What are some
things that interest you? And think
about how is that could become pillars
for growing your personal brand and
therefore your company's brand.
I wish you the best of luck winning your
share of the pie and DM me to talk about
your go-to-market. Thank you.